there is a dangerous situation right now  windy weather fueling more wildfires in  california  this morning the silverado fire in  orange county has grown to 2  000 acres here's a live look here this  is the silverado fire burning in orange  county near irvine right now  sixty thousand people under mandatory  evacuation orders  further north uh firefighters in  northern california they have also  pre-positioned themselves  they did that overnight to quickly  respond to any more fires  right now there are fifty 300 wildfire  firefighters  uh statewide trying to contain the 21  fires burning  so far in california this year more than  8.6 million acres have burned sure it is  a dangerous situation once again in  california  and it's those with high winds